what a fool
what's up fool with
what's up fool podcast with Felipe
Esparza and Rodrigo Torres yeah man
and Lisa Esparza what's up fool
man we're back we have a guest today
from east los hi yeah I might have known
that show from Hulu it's a whole new TV
they've been on for I don't know man
they have seasons 500 episodes I don't
know man but you could bend watch been
binge binge watch the first two seasons
also I wrote for the show the last one
of the thirteen in the poor season you
might recognize a couple of my jokes are
through in there couple of tags like I
rewrote it up some good lines in there
didn't get asked to come back to next
season and I'm off the I can't tell you
guys why but but my suspicion is they
had another comedian there who the lead
writer and you know when you have a
comedian there who's writing for the
show and then they hire another comedian
to tag it up I mean and look for
punchlines that means that comedian
wasn't funny he was shaking in his boots
not even funny on paper everything I
could that's a friend of Camila I was
hot that was funny
I know him I'll get making stuff up but
I was up you know man comedians man
comedians anybody who entered in the
entertainment business for example no
examples
I'm the example we always think there's
someone out to get us or it was because
somebody is plotting against them we
don't get stuff and then you get stuff
and you realize man I was to pay all
this time that's waste
oh yeah like I would like to think I'm
how come not getting booked but then I
realize only people who don't who who
don't get on the 101
Nords know who you are you are funny
you're famous from here to the 605 and
money and you know what that's true
because every time I perform pass the
605 to show they're sold out now Ontario
cuz you do a lot of shows over there
back in the days man like there were a
lot of shows to make $100 like somebody
or one show pop out somewhere
hell yeah cuz it stick it up like they
were helping on a show like Sebastian
Athena we have a show in farbe remember
here to show really for Blythe Blythe
and people showed up I don't know where
they came from
I know but also man I don't know a lot
of Alex lodges like I will perform and
Alex largest those people weren't it's
funny it's good to perform and I'm very
fortunate to perform at shows where they
know I'm coming they know what they're
gonna expect before all the shows were
like we're having a comedy show today
and this week we have Toby hates Felipe
Esparza wheels were the real toria's you
know whatever they put you with anybody
right I feel like a potpourri of
comedians and people choose who they
like people walk out during the show I
would say probably about walk out during
the show they get up I didn't like I
didn't like the show we can't give you
your money back
fine you know I have to do man most of
the show where people didn't like me all
they did was get up and go play pinball
shoot pool for a little bit on so then
we talked about Boulder Colorado last
week no we didn't straight to the stuff
yeah going straight to a show we have
fun in Boulder by the way it was cold it
was cold we went to a shop shout-out to
that guy I'm there to go to that shop
what was it the fourteener the
fourteener
shout out to the fourteener the biggest
the the biggest shop against one of the
best jobs and grow up
[ __ ] in Boulder they took her to the
warehouse man mice jacket still steams
dude I've never seen that much but like
the one and it was good yeah that's how
you know the grower for the non growers
like that me
I've grown one plant and it's it's never
gone in that big or that large but I did
get to the nugs but I didn't wait long
enough to smoke it like I was excited
bro oh dude everybody messes up the
first batch huh most of the time though
you'd be lucky if you do get a good a
good strong plan but if you were to grow
your own pot in your house legally like
it like it's supposed to right now is
legally you can you legally grow up to
what six plants
yeah if you grow your own pot you see
growing your own pot in your house you
know like somewhere here away from the
kids you make your own box you can
pretty much top your own box your own
weed box didn't happen like that on that
water heater container you were doing
the report only on outside I've done it
on the inside you would like that
cleared off nah dude when I was 17 I
grew one and I thought they're gonna rip
it out but they're looking cool they
come out yeah dude it was bomb so
they're to go to the process they took
us to the where all the plants are at
let me have that please dog and then we
work on the way there right man
remember when we're driving there the
drivers not look smell it right now you
can smell the weed the guy that owns six
helicopters yeah our driver dominican
guy you took us driving through radio we
were coming from Denver he goes papa
lower the windows we lower the windows
nothing gonna take a whiff and let me
tell you man the freeway smell like pot
yeah outside the car like pot like aroma
and they have it inside warehouses but
all the exhaust going outside oh yeah it
was a one percenter you know Indian
driver yeah man and we still like to
look where the plants were due to the
place where the plants are being stored
and hung oh yeah that was fun
dude Oh stinky hell yeah what's over
those our biggest budget ever seen you
I could've slept in there even if you
don't like we do come on you can't tell
me it doesn't smell good man you guys
would have you got would have say if you
would have seen the trim room you want
to sell yourself man
I would like to scrape that resident
knife those scissors that's what I'm
saying how the bowl
how much Keith was talking to you there
was like scissors like three or four
scissors they were just like open that
you know that they had like scraped that
[ __ ] off to get him to work again yeah
you're gonna use like alcohol yeah
because I touch when I tried it wouldn't
wouldn't close them with full of resin
and they use everything they recycle
everything we want you to trash can and
there's only stakes yeah because they
even use those that they track something
out of there they get all the leftover
buds or the trim to make wax and to make
a moil
and to make edibles yeah and a little of
water you might think Mary put it with a
lot of water no man breeze it they reuse
it they they reuse the dirty water and
they keep using and they keep using it
even though they don't waste nothing
yeah it's all like why don't go be
expensive [ __ ] yeah dude how could the
coldest place ever been to have so much
weed it was fun man we got through the
night before we walked to the long walk
which what pizza place everybody was
nice there until that bro yeah
and we did the show it was packed people
showed up the show's nuts too Toby was
cold and he's gonna freeze my toes we
thought it was called him Boulder he
gets colder though he was cold we were
there was a Carboni Johnny Rocky was it
um did you know how to work the camera
he needed the code or the password I
thought even the camera works great
wouldn't do a bit with nagira
I see the video there doing Johnny
Walker the videos are good good writing
we got [ __ ] with scarce a we can fly
them out you pay
put him on the show a [ __ ] can't feel
my [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't understand
hello my buddy wasted charged [ __ ]
that's it we'll just bring me Guerra
with us another video would look good
will be anyway I'm not saying anything
are we I haven't already told him by the
way so don't know Malik they'd never be
yelled at I never yell bro you [ __ ]
serious dude give me a break and then
Mario Martin his his side wait no no
what was that oh no Martin took a video
that food cuz shout out to shout out to
a styrofoam Foreman sharpie great
Mexican vegan food and they made a bunch
of tacos and stuff for you guys rice and
beans but you didn't see any of it
except the pico de gallo yeah all the
other packages were closed
Martin's running on his phone over the
table of styrofoam package it's like
look at this great food and none of it
was Marcela and Sandra I was like look
it's pinky in the crew trying to redeem
ourselves funny man up Rizzo had a cold
sore the whole week you can't even see
it oh you can see a dog I did the up
close the suit the zoom ins with the I
mean this is hilarious metaphor say Oh
Bailey you know when people have a fever
blister and what they call it first they
set out
kengo-san bro who wait will you cover it
up bro will you lighten is here oh
that's why here indoors
who slept with it and then they wanted
to go away cuz make it grow and then we
asked them bro I asked him which we
haven't there he was all mad beginnings
over little bro take a photo of that
chance and it's your lady goes down
where's your lady she the expert on cold
sores but nah cuz the one time I had a
cold sir I could even kiss her for a
week after dog but um but you know what
the little guy said fool at the airport
are you gonna go home and she's gonna
see the cold sore no no she already
knows about it she kiss me already bro
she's ready to die
he has a matching one Toby made you
thought I made a mess of face being cold
oh I told that bro I told that fool but
yeah [ __ ] go to a bathroom try that
[ __ ]
grab some wax out of here wax your wax
and put it right there bro go to sleep
cuz I said a picture of my ladies on
nope that's a cold it's like your water
bug name yeah I know man and in New York
man he didn't want to be next he'd wanna
be next to a Louise goose - my papa was
so full forgot to mention we had Louie
Guzman from the podcast you know here
for the podcast you need a favor
and Pechanga yeah Boogie Nights
that fool man that fool took took call
me back to 1990 that fool flora there
for throwing chocolate the audio bro
no really he had a bag and I come here a
bag and I'm thinking man what is it in
that bag and I'm starting my Bechet I
feel gonna bust out something out of
that bag on stage
whatever is lunch wool that food so he
went up there telling what happened bro
you saw the whole show ha ha do this
fool was [ __ ] happy first of all
excited jumping up and down
[ __ ] with a jersey that's a Lower
East Side yeah low each side that's just
like favorite son right there dude he
came with a little entourage dude he's
on stage it's all gravy but uh he went
on stage man he gave him the whole
little Puerto Rican experience with the
mother dog and that's when he pulled out
that chunk leather dude he talks about
for those in the audience smacking heads
he's got nobody sue me then the after
party but they're gonna be waiting for
him with a chocolate imagine if
everybody were waiting for us to the
chocolate you're beating him with it
that'll be a good video she was happy
man he was happy dog I don't even know
he had material he just went up there
huh story I think people weren't
expecting him nah dude people tripped
out dude it was - it was cool man
he was happy bro and oh man there was a
meeting greet of course you know man I
get starstruck when I see legends you
know being that uh Louie Guzman II from
the Lower East Side I don't know if you
guys ever heard of jean-michel Basquiat
and I mean if you ever seen a movie
Basquiat you remember that um in the
movie jean-michel Basquiat he had um a
friend in a movie who was played by but
he's sort of Toro and that was homeboy
and together they were like they were
like part of a tagging crew called same
ole same ole was the same old [ __ ] yeah
and the guy was there I mean these guys
were in the movie I remember them in the
movie jumping him and oh man so
shout-out to Danny Minich and also man
also the the guy that
Danny minik same MO and we got Al Diaz
there artist and man I wish I would have
got to the art studio but now next time
I go to New York I'm definitely gonna go
to the art studio and check out our
other styles look him up man his name is
Danny Minich and my a nice and I see
Kate and the other guy is el Diaz and
they're both artists from the Lower East
Side and they put him on represent if
you look at the art you're gonna see the
similarities between him and the old
school style of John Basquiat and they
started that stylist here they started a
style they have merged and they have
good man I wish I would have more time
to talk to them but I'm so brief and
these guys were like they did this some
of the Bombers original social movement
graffiti from back in the days you
recognize it yeah with the hip hop
movement and all that those dudes been
doing great for G started 40 years at
least four they go back all the way to
beat Street Hammond like when it was the
grungees the grungy [ __ ] New York
those guys were they know your friend
mm-hmm Suzanne when I was living in New
York well first of all there was a
squatter movement around that time too
in the early 90s so yeah it's that was
like the end of that art movement but
Debbie Harry used to hang out with
Basquiat and those people it was like
you know Andy Warhol that era but
what's-his-face mascots lady wasn't
named Suzanne Maloof Maloof in the movie
though they call her Gina something but
Julian Schnabel who who made the movie
director and writer he was like a kind
of like good kind of like a hanger-on
this is how it described to me by
Suzanne Julian was a hanger-on to the
art community he was kind of a little
more he was jealous of Basquiat all the
time and didn't he didn't reach the
level of acknowledgement as Basquiat you
know but he took this story and he made
it into a movie but he basically
changed her character enough so he
didn't have to pay her for use of her
likeness or anything like that
but everybody knew it was her he's got a
painting called Suzanne as well and
that's that's Suzanne but anyway she was
my boss at a restaurant she went through
this period of like homelessness and
yeah [ __ ]
and then but she was Persian and she her
family expected more her whole family
was like professionals and stuff you
know about it and so she was kind of
shunned by them for a while but then she
was working as a manager at Mesa Grill
Bobby Flay's restaurant when I worked
there and um she was my manager for like
a year and a half and she would tell me
stories of hanging out over there yeah
now she's a [ __ ] pediatrician out of
nowhere I mean I'm sorry pediatric
psychologists is what she does
so she she had those little kids like
that she's a professional in her field
now it's so weird like this woman lived
on the streets with Basquiat and now
she's a pediatrician
not originally her family I don't know
where what area her she grew up there we
met I'm Louis goes my son shout-out to
him his name is Sammy Guzman that fool
he looked a lot like God the young
wasn't he like Aquaman right here though
Lisa Bonet was a little version of that
fool yeah that's kickin it with them at
that party at they were all they're all
cool people man did you see that little
fool that look my Chapel that other I
don't know who the artist that Sloane
for Dawg that's another four yeah that's
him famous yeah we were hanging out with
them at that thing I know he say rocks
Victor Ramos dr. Ramos did you give a
little poetry slash they had a rapper
that was named Rama who died in a show
my man Ramon yeah man that fool is cool
as [ __ ]
and a goose but right here brother where
my Tito sued and I need to go over there
and do so in a summer abroad just to
hang out over there to that loading site
is great we barely even like do
like to Lower East Side is a mix of old
Jewish neighborhood and the Puerto Rican
Dominicans who moved in later but it's
cool you can go in a pickle tour they
have a pickle making cuz there's a lot
of delis down there rich Illinois
bellies and they used to be this area I
don't even know if it is anymore but it
was like it was like the alleys you know
here Santee alley but over there it's
called Orchard Street and it was all
these mostly Russian Jewish merchants in
open-air sort of stands selling stuff
and leather jackets and you know all
sorts of stuff
shout out man to everybody out there
that thing is ridiculous gotta talk
about this man what happened for man
with a man how the [ __ ] you tea is gonna
start a new California and not expect to
get [ __ ] jumped in by the rest of
California look you know the kind of
store nights a gangster [ __ ] state you
just can't leave without getting jumped
out [ __ ] man to get your turn of
California we got a couch of pity
because I have 50 states plus we'll be
so pissed off
we might add two more States Puerto Rico
and the Virgin Islands now we got 52
seconds or getting a beatdown
[ __ ] that [ __ ] we might add Jamaica in
there 53 seconds man how the [ __ ] are
you gonna say this tide and they say
we're gonna take clear ourselves we
don't get it we don't get treated right
by the by the our boats don't count
I'm sticking tired man or people that
crying over here saying that my vote
doesn't count my vote doesn't count
we're gonna start a new California [ __ ]
that [ __ ] man
you can start a new California without
getting jumped out dude what we need are
Co our vote doesn't count man let me
tell you man
our vote I think about your boat not
counting the whole group the whole
Senate is Republican
our Congress is Republican we got a
Republican president come on man your
vote counted I think they're talking
about locally they're pissed locally
they want all this Oh the role here by
the way sorry
David don't go cow alternative news but
just a move now goes to a man like
they're just crying but you know they
took all the good parts bro no they did
they left those like if you if you see
how its divided it's um they keep San
Diego you know what man
San Diego man they're 82 charger so we
took everything we could possibly take
for you we're gonna take frog next we'll
take frog and that's what's gonna living
over here in Lancaster that's the part
neighborhood he will blend win well
though anyway so the way the body is all
of Los Angeles but not part of the
Angeles to find the good side like in
Calabasas yeah so it's always from Los
Angeles in the into San Francisco
we keep San Mateo we keep Santa Cruz but
two tickets that house April how the
[ __ ] it takes time stay without asking
the people in San Jose and they want to
remain part of the old California better
that's a deaconess first day they're
stupid Mac because their sales done it
represent it right you're not gonna get
represented in about more cuz now we're
gonna have four news Senate's in
California because we need to in the old
state and we need two new ones so though
it'll still be the same don't know more
about me nothin see what nothing's gonna
happen with that stuff dude it's just a
movement they want to try to get it on
the ballot ain't nothing gonna happen
nothing whatsoever all the announcements
but I don't I don't think I don't think
anything's gonna happen it's just a
movement I remember when what was two
years ago they try to get a little
California fourteen again that's another
battle doing this separate California
through four stay with Northern
California Southern Cal
Southern California and in California
there's no way that's gonna happen to
you know it's just dumb gerrymandering
bro
you know I'm from the Republican it's
hard for them to win over here and by
the way anybody listening on here we're
not getting political we're not picking
sides we just stayed a fact by how
stupid
the bike California where we're one
nation under God right for California
man will redefine anyways man we know
they're to California's in prison we
know it's a powder
we know the cutoff is in Bakersfield
[Laughter]
Fresno anyways it was a new California
they're checking Fresno bro he's taken
all the lands where there's farms yeah
well it's all like based on an
agricultural we're stuck with Holly
Nanami Morro Bay ain't nothing gonna
happen still gonna be California do
stronger than ever with all the division
happening in the country do you think
that's gonna bother us to stop
attraction stop it already
so this direction dude could you hear
all that [ __ ] when they always cry
about the water you know Northern
California dude what's got to do with us
we're by you getting a chat right we're
thirsty come on enough magic for now
bandit that um 239 pounds of the new 280
you know right yeah bro
when I saw 200 that when it went up
riveting at the checker for 209 he's six
foot three and I'm thinking to myself
within that [ __ ] six four two
two years ago how the gates holler and
we're getting shorter the best grows an
extra inch better than me and I'm not
hearing a president I'm not here and
anything about him I'm just hating as a
fat person not fat and I know what it's
239 looks like exactly if you mean in
2002 bro
I only say it was 239 I said I gotta be
no way
whoo that's fake 6 4 3 239 no man no man
no no I'm asked to say no because I'm 6
foot 1 285 when I'm lucky and when I got
to sleep on 293 you know that porn star
knows that definitely no 239 there you
go bro
not even a fact yet artifact he's she
said that she has sex with with shrub
for month after I warn you and then like
when during the pregnancy see man that's
something only a man will do only a man
would do something like that and you
know what man everybody's guilty of that
don't beep no be Jenna
talk about the president because he does
stuff like that we've all done that we
all should we watch someone when my son
was born I was driving some chicks car
[Laughter]
there you go naming names oh I was like
Henry Hill in Goodfellas when they guy
comes a shot you know tell you what's in
that guy it was like that it was like it
was like it was like the murder yeah it
was like the guy dying and Tim Roth dog
having the third miscarriage she was
over to miscarry when I was driving in
traffic I was just passing on napkins
bit of depends she was like bleeding in
the back like Tim Roth and Rutherford
arcs I was shot
I wish I don't die on me he was sneaking
peeks at what was going on he was like
what the hell I was body parts come out
everything else that's funny when she
miscarries this time that doors that
only the rabbit was in the bag at this
scarab rule just stared at the back just
focusing I don't know yeah man we had a
woman with a miscarriage Phillippe it
worried about the show the rabbit aback
scare staring at
Isaac's backpack we got Isaac worried
about
gonna play games when he gets there he
thinks about are they gonna have cheese
to expect they're gonna have grilled
cheese I don't know how we got here but
we're here now I don't know oh man do
that oh yeah that would happen man I
just pissed off over there about every
time so much I just first I won't even
matter when um when no wonder they are
now is a president-elect I was mad the
people that were how they reacted in
California when president strongly like
there was some divisive [ __ ] rolling
we're gonna [ __ ] Cersei for the
nation come on man if used to nobody's
gonna succeed from this nation man I
don't want to see seed I don't want to
go back to Mexico I don't wanna get the
poured in for some reason I follow the
rules
cuz I love playing behind the rules here
I don't want to play behind the rules in
another country I never been to can't go
there every time and only tell me what
Mexico is for nothing I don't know no I
know my family's over there and they
want to visit me come on down man we
live for a reasons you know for a better
life so we were poor we it's better to
be poor in America than to be poor in
Mexico but they don't give a [ __ ] about
you there's no leg they're never there
never a speech by anybody hold on then
I'm okay I god I love pobres
forgetfulness report on today Mexico
it's only a hint there multipotent la la
sangre de pais you never hear speeches
like that only in America
we're gonna help out the poor and
because of the blood of this country see
any rich Mexican people leave in Mexico
hell no man and another thing man when
I'm Trump said this is not a joke or
Baggins is it a comedy joke cuz comedian
we write jokes he said how come white
people never come from Norway you know
why could they have free dental over
there they're free benefit health care
every time at white people why there's
no white poor people that want to come
over here they're good where they're at
they don't want to sneak over here and
pay for college or section eight they
don't want to pay for college
like in Czechoslovakia white people over
there like what we were married over
there and Lisa gets pregnant she gonna
be pregnant she could leave work and
still get paid
and decide when she wants to come back
in Australia you get like $5,000 when
you have a baby from the state from the
government from the country you know
what I mean like you get you get $5,000
you get a year off of work you get
midwifery care in a midwife Hospital
over there that's crazy
the only way white people from Europe
are gonna die to go to America and we
bombed their country we start a war
right now these prog [ __ ]
these chicks you start bombing them then
they want to come over here cuz then you
don't want to leave the party while the
party is still going on we had Norwegian
immigrants many years ago and they were
poor before their economy I had four
percent nor we didn't showed up on my
DNA I was surprised at that and I'm
Irish we all stole all the jobs first
little clover do you want to do the show
announce mr. you want me to do it I'll
just zip through him faster though
January 19th tomorrow morning I think
I'm gonna put this up Thursday night
10:00 a.m. Boyle Heights primera these'
on first Street Felipe's doing a
meet-and-greet coffee with Felipe from
10 to about 12 he also be selling
tickets to his la shows March 23rd and
you could pay cash he could pay card no
service fees added on to the tickets and
he's also gonna be selling his vinyl
album in person there and signing them
if you buy one there and we also take
cash on card for those January 20th
Coachella at spotlight 29 I sold out
January 27th Tucson Arizona desert
diamond casino so Atit the Arizona that
is almost sold out the handful of
tickets left
February 1st through 3rd Naples Florida
off the hook comedy club February 14th
Valentine's Day Corpus Christi American
Bank Center with Raymond northa Raymond
or - and be a fun in show because women
Horta is hardcore cowboy fan like
paronella Bella and she that's how he
blew up by ranting that cowboy thing and
I've kind of blew up my cell by ranting
that dodgy thing but I'm a Raider fan
I'll be funny man I'm aware my Raiders
Jersey when I see him yeah you should be
a little bitter when we get there
yeah so February 4th that's tickets are
on sale now for that
February 22nd Lemoore California up by
Fresno area Central Valley
Tachi Casino February 23rd Las Vegas
Nevada Treasure Island Casino February
24th Rochester Washington lucky Eagle
Casino a lot of things were sophomores
do go how'd it go last night for that
black was sure it was good we have good
little turnout to [ __ ] raise some
money for a fluckey
Oh and gave him his envelope this
morning so thank you to all the comics
that came out looking skinny blue
skeleton key yeah a little skinnier do
they open them up through the middle
dude the sternum dude so you know they
went through his procedures be home in a
couple days hopefully and then be nice
and back to regular Flaco in about a
couple weeks breaking us good yeah
looking skinny though he's killing him
before yeah he could walk through a harp
[Laughter]
were some fools man what else we got
going on bro that's it we haven't talked
about shy town remember that was really
cold we will shut up Chicago man man
we're with the tiniest rooms but it was
the best like a room no we had a sweet
look in the living room it was man 7
degrees and everybody what I don't want
to do nothing
post mates channel 2 there man for
delivery me food we have to go outside I
was freezing I don't know you just kill
people over there bro all day long hey
who's calling me you me no you know I'm
[ __ ] cold pop what are they fighting
for you know what happened man
you know why people fight in Chicago for
people don't talk about this it's
because yeah you had I'm 3,000 people
that used to live in one building
Cabrini Green
Green you got the other other project
Wharton Robert warden and he got another
housing project we're talking like
10,000 people they got displaced and
they got sent to different neighborhoods
let me tell you when you send 10,000
different hoods to different
neighborhoods a new hood it's gonna
start over there so you know so this
gangbanging brother just like when they
built the [ __ ] they when they built the
East LA exchange freeway in Boyle
Heights in 1960 something like they used
to be they broke down so many houses
they needs to lay to build off the four
freeway the 60 the 101 the 5 and the 10
to meet together they forgot that there
was gangs down there too bro it was one
big gang back then white fence and then
he broke that up now that's a gang and
diamond Street cuz you know the people
franchise gangbang yeah bro yeah man
like my neighborhood disappeared but I
heard that my neighborhood didn't know
again it's in San Bernardino because a
lot of people from my neighborhood move
San Bernardino so they have over there
um you know there was a different story
yeah in the nineties when everybody went
to laugh cats or Palmdale Moreno Valley
that [ __ ] spread out there bro and
everybody from South Central last are
central to move to Moreno Valley to be
safer now Moreno Valley [ __ ] up that
was more Negroes and also more there no
value for Mexicans you mean ice cube
move over there eazy-e moved to
Riverside screamin Compton but you moved
to Riverside yeah and I love my homeboy
they move to Lancaster Lancaster Flats
so that's what we talk to the Chicago
cop dude was about what's going down
right there's a mad war right now with
all those gangs coming together and like
drug dealing
people are dying left and right I didn't
I'm glad if I know you with a cop
because I was always gonna ask you man
with a good place run with corner tomoko
joint who I had a good time man the last
day the last night I roll up that guy
from the hotel room Andy shut out to
Andy first of all man if you plan on
going to New York
and if you're a pot smoker like
ourselves bring your own blunts okay
bring your own Swisher bring your own
back would bring your own Philly blunt
bring your own raps bring your own
zigzags they don't sell none of that in
Manhattan
none of that cigarettes are $19 a pack I
quit
years ago and blunts just one blood will
cost me $4 so if you want to start a
business in Manhattan showed up with
five boxes of Swisher's extending a
cornerman asylum I wouldn't recommend
that if I end up like Eric Gardner [ __ ]
that's why he got shot for them selling
the lucy's you gotta choke that by the
cop but that one couple in Chicago his
name's Jose Jara Jara he's got order of
the hovitos company were so fool we have
a guest to date Vanessa
[Laughter]
Vasquez we don't give presents to
anybody everybody because you know we
break easy will easily attack you
you're in a conversation with somebody
and you don't like that person already
but then you mention something and you
want to think about your [ __ ]
we're sensitive yeah mother and yet the
women we mentioned it earlier she is the
star of east los hi the only character
have been there forever everybody else
they got a young one or older one how
did that come about
I met the East Los hi it's a popular
show on Hulu man I been watching the
first two seasons bro like I was hooked
like you were like we were so we're so
hooked on they're like like if my wife
would have watched it before me I
thought she was cheating on me you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] watch that [ __ ] don't worry
I saw her in the bus - man it was good
man it's about relationships bro about
cheating pregnancy and immigration and
all those problems get solved in a dance
contest oh dude but this is traumatic
bro because sometimes like I remember
the first season there was a lot of bad
chicks you know like oh like I want her
to be in the next year that I want her
to be listening and you root for them
but then like they didn't come back but
I don't want to spoil it man but they
won't ever came back as a coach over
there I mean it's not marketed toward
you or your age at all it's Mugabe Boyle
Heights I said this show is legit like
so tell you watch your show but
instantly there's a bunch of white
hipsters you know from Arkansas and
there's another lingo and they're cheeky
numb water juice Mexican juice play real
chata
put on my glasses my hair my loo like
like [ __ ] I look like a Mexican biker on
trial
but there's a vascular ladies and
gentlemen she plays camellia from East
lows hi Camilla Camilla or something
else in America me let akela you gotta
watch the short to know that one from
Galveston Texas
whoa man well I was born in Galveston
I'm really from Houston Texas but you
been to Galveston though yeah she showed
up in a storm
damn it's really close to ours rival
Houston I don't know why we did that
right the whole time we're driving I
keep the girl blue now let me get a car
accident it was draw two hours in
Galveston and then when we get there
we're stuck in traffic forever we're
never moving we're not moving and then I
told him I you better part something
wrong here you know what we were in a
parade Mardi Gras yes we were in a
parade
yes we didn't know man Park we part and
then we walk to the beach Galveston one
of the beaches that we jump on the pier
you're gonna get crucified by an old
building that used to be there yeah
hurricane sandy beat that place up beat
it up Galveston is like set the standard
Cruz of Texas it's real nice in hard
that man shark right there all it looks
like Martine yeah
so that's Galveston story her family's
from Monterrey Mexico raised by a single
mother and her grandmother sounds like
me bro every Mexican story my whele a
diner what redneck with biological
father in Mexico redneck reconnected
okay
he knows more about me than this true
cuz I don't wanna be wrong did you work
your mouth diner yeah when I first got
here yeah that's true story when she
moved to LA went to Stella Adler Academy
right next to those tacos right there
now thought I wanna go Boulevard now
went to the one on Hollywood almost you
do that Hollywood Boulevard no oh the
other one the other one I'm talking
about the other guy the one that came
out in Roth him yes he Nikki Molly and
yeah him Hyman Roth oh yeah I thought
you went to that one no I thought about
going to that one but they're like now
you're already crazy enough let's let's
go to Stella Adler I was like alright
that's cool how does a group of
Galveston Texas decided she wants to be
an actress well you know it's crazy
because I mean I grew up right outside
of Houston like 30 minutes out in a
little small town called Richmond Texas
right and like that we grew up behind
the tracks like the hood is so like
Hollywood and everything seems so
far-fetched like you think to yourself
like okay one you're Hispanic you've
grown up with a single mom you know
there's no time like my mom never had
enough money to put me in acting classes
do all that stuff it was always like you
know you know pay all the bills we got
to do all this and all that and so I
just never thought of it as a something
I could do one thing she did instill me
was like you have to go to college no
matter what you do you're gonna be the
first one to graduate high school you're
gonna be the first one to go to college
and you have to like finish it so she
had planted that seed in my head since I
was a little girl so I was like yeah and
as soon as I I left high school I just
wanted to come to LA I was like no I
want to go I want to go to Hollywood you
know I want to go take classes there and
she's like no mija look you gotta go to
school
porque si no no bother money and I was
like you know it's like that mentality
of like that theatre doesn't bring you
money you know or the acting doesn't
give you money so I was like
okay fine you know I gotta finish it and
then afterwards you know I went through
some things you know I was I pretty much
did everything that they needed me to do
and then one day I was just like you
know what I'm gonna go like I'm just
gonna leave and that was hard you know
cuz I had to tell my aunt's I had to
tell my grandma my mom and like they
were just like well what do you mean
you're gonna leave us like you don't
love us no more and I was like no I do
it's just I have to go do stuff you know
I have to go follow my heart that
Wonderwoman leaving the island for the
way you lose all your powers yeah
something like that
going over the show that used to watch
and say man I want to be something like
that well you know it wasn't even
anything that like I grew up watching in
telenovelas you know my swatch Saved by
the Bell Fresh Prince I related to a lot
of those but I loved reading books you
know I would just hide in and look I was
really quiet and shy so I would like
hide in a corner and like read my books
and I and I'd imagine myself being these
characters I'm really playing them out
and it was until I got to middle school
and the teacher handed me a script and
it was like little like fairy dust that
kind of just came over me and I was like
oh my god I love this like I love this
character like I love you know the
structure now and they're just from
there and I just I took theater classes
in school you know I was like you know
I'm just gonna do whatever I can you
know maybe my mom doesn't have money but
that doesn't mean I can't do whatever I
can with my means of you know my
resources so yeah I just kept thinking
it but I kept my dreams quiet I wouldn't
tell people like that I had dreams of to
do stuff like this because you know like
people don't believe they're like now
well you think you're all bad or what
actually a lot of the time I never told
my friend I want to be a comedian man I
want to join a couple of people like
together used to help me out
arms metrics Robert was named Hendricks
country whatever his name was ladi Dadi
you know you are the project northeast
part Cal you know
is it was the first guy I told I want to
be a comedian but I wanted to bro like I
wanted to be desired but I never saw it
like as work I just wanted I don't want
to be famous
I just want to make people laugh wanna
see the reaction I wanted feedback bro
what around the narrows book right
abroad with the narrow line in and mad
glory madman glory when he playing a
stand-up comedian no Bill Murray mad
doggin glory goes I should I choose to
be a technical medium because I you I
but it says I expect adulation first III
won a one arm nevermind let's move on I
cry I crave approval yeah alright
alright calm when people need attention
they're like they need to do it for
attention yeah some people say you need
to do people do that [ __ ] for attention
but I don't believe that maybe some
performers but not all oh I know what
you're playing in movies when they have
a round table and everybody lap in a
family is talking like you pass out all
the forks and they spook that's a little
one for some reason bro it's a little
brother
yeah we try to be off bad you know
that's funny because that's one of the
things that I noticed about a lot of
I've been meeting a lot of really
successful like stand-up comedians like
yourself and like actors and people that
that really are genuine and come from
like a you know that you did just they
talk about that how they just got that
feeling
one day you know they're like I just I
felt like I needed to do this and I was
scared I don't know who to tell you know
so I kept my dream private or like I
would tell some people and then there at
last so every time something like that
would happen you know there just protect
that dream it's like The Pursuit of
Happyness you know what they say is that
you got a dream you got to protect it
you know people are gonna tell you they
can't you can't do something because
they can't do it for themselves
so I hold on to the head and they're
gonna happen like in the movies man like
you watching you watch you know a movie
it's dark and you're scared by yourself
and then old gypsy lady walks up to you
you're gonna be the Wolfman Jamie nobody
picks you up man and I think it just
happens bro yeah and the way you become
famous it's not by your choice is the
audience it's we're like the audience
knows who's gonna gravitate you for some
reason so many people like I'm gonna be
famous but you get there you don't have
the extra somebody wow you have that
thanks I'm still trying to figure out
what that in fact there is it's like
when Neal Brennan used to ask you why
aren't you in more movies in fact I'm
like I'm a clown
[Laughter]
you know what was the first roll you
ever got you know it's funny I was
listening to your one of your podcast
with Chingo Bling the other day and my
very first like no TV gig was tingling
music video are you serious yeah Texas
Houston yeah down at the taco shack it
was it was a walk like little music
video and it was crazy because I went in
there like I was at the club you know
with my homegirls Dean and they were
passing out flyers like hey you know
we've got this audition we're looking
for dancers and actors and at the time I
was taking theater and I was like
I'm going in with my monologue on my
headshot they're gonna like someone's
gonna cast me but I didn't really
it didn't say on there what it was
forward they didn't put jingle bling or
nothing
okay so I went in I showed up to this
hotel and they had like ollie there was
tons of girls out there that's like a
huge cattle call they all had numbers on
there like about to run a marathon and
so they just slapped the number on me
and I waited my turn and then when I
finally got up there and it was like a
whole panel like this right of all dudes
and then the director like they mean he
was like okay we're gonna go ahead and
play the song and then you start dancing
and I was like oh wait like hold on
what's going on and they're like what do
you think this is it's a music video
audition I was like oh I'm sorry I
didn't know I was like I I thought it
was um I thought it was some audition
you know we're looking for actors he was
like and they all started busting out
laughing at me Ichigo they were all
laughing I was like um I'm starting what
did you prepare I was like I prepared my
monologue and the director was like okay
um guys hold on one second so he took me
to the side he was like look you got a
monologue and I was like yeah I got my
headshot got my my resume he was like he
looked at it turned around he goes how
long you've been acting outside for a
while but like I haven't really done was
just mostly theatre and then he was like
okay okay but look this is a music video
audition you're still gonna have to they
can have to see if your twerk works and
I was like all right so they like these
are can you dance those like yeah I mean
I I can you know I could pop lock and
drop it and so they like put the song on
that was like shingle was doing and I
did a little freestyle hip-hop and then
that then they were just like alright
thank you we'll call you and I was like
man I didn't get it you know so I left
and then like a week later some lady
calls me she's like you don't call me
back or what and I was like I'm sorry
wouldn't she's like I've been calling
you and I was like for what tinkling and
they're all like I got to meet them on
and I'm like good friends uper ching
going us never jinglun no they're all
hustlers
yes cross so yeah and then they just
call me and they're like yeah you got
the you got the lead part and I was like
all right cool
it's funny but I picture you showing up
ready with your your tutu in your tap
dance shoes I was like I think I was
like 19 yeah the Hustle real you was
there minute you look away man las
conchas here no the thing is that they
didn't pay attention to me I walked into
here and makeup and I like I'm pretty
I'm pretty skinny you know is I'm
already look 19 I was looking like I was
11 years old you know so all the girls
in there with voluptuous big old titties
and like big butts and everything and so
they were looking at me - yeah they were
looking at me like oh it's just an extra
you know so they'd like threw me this
side and so I was waiting and waiting
and then finally the director come he's
like hey what are you doing either
I need the route they would call me the
rooster girl like I mean I had to pick
up a real rooster like I stole his
rooster at the club that was a whole
like premise and so it's a crazy video
like can you get it ready and they're
like oh whoa and they're like her and I
was like it's a little twig in the
corner like oh yeah come on get over
here girl and so like fix me up and then
they finally threw me out there and he's
like okay we're gonna give you a rooster
you're good with chickens right and I
was like yeah I mean we had a couple of
them growing up I think I'm fine I just
can't kill them no no no it's fine so
they like game they like handed me a
rooster just like threw it on me and
EXCI knows the rooster girl that is
crazy ass video
hey bro you're held a pitbull hold on to
killer right here that is crazy you show
up on us are they gonna hold a chicken
know your role he's stealing a chicken
Wow
imagine man all those chicken they came
to audition for that role
there was a prize chicken showed up come
on I've been KFC commercials I was
scared that I thought it was gonna be
like a like one of those fighting
roosters you know but it wasn't it was
actually his real pet rooster named
after a sling for the cockscomb I've
heard that no no that's great I think I
was up here was so cool we're here with
Vanessa Vasquez from East Los hi how
many season that on well we just
finished last year was the season finale
I mean series finale we did like it was
shot a movie and we like the shows done
so we did five years oh oh five or there
was four seasons but this last year we
did a movie to wrap it up so it's like
five years yeah yeah that was 24 yeah
because they came with a finished we met
I can't remember the name the Cuban guy
but there was a few of people that
started off in the beginning and then
yes changed after stealing too but we
had a development meeting with him maybe
no he was he hired me to write funny
lines for you and I wrote a line when I
think it's your older mom it kicked on
the dad yeah I wrote a funny line for
her right there oh really
well line was
man it was about I would like the
domestic joke that I did it no it was
like your molestation thing yeah III
Gabriel molestation line that was pretty
funny but it was hardcore hardcore yeah
yeah I said what did I say oh yeah when
you get my night you say when you get
molested in a Latino house it's always
your fault
it's always your oh yeah yeah they never
come up to you they never asked you what
happened where you hurt us always what
were you wearing
yeah well what did you do I give her
that line yeah I remember you wearing a
terrible joke about it's a perfect life
for the lady right there because she's
from her former character what were you
wearing
because they blame it on you okay he
touched me yeah it's hard to watch that
show man but it's good show cuz they're
scenes they're like Vanessa's character
she was sexually molested by your father
right mm-hmm
and then like if you never been in a
situation like that you would know that
it's hard to tell somebody and and then
like it feels like um it's like when you
have a friend a best friend and that's
your best friend but then you have it
this other [ __ ] who used to be your
friend but you know this [ __ ]
evil he's vile he's a rock he's a thief
he's a piece of [ __ ] but your new best
your other friend like some but you
don't wanna like you know you don't know
how to tell them you know like morning
this is a piece of [ __ ] because they're
not gonna believe you you don't look mad
that's hard to watch on that show but
it's good it's good man good yeah I
still get emails from people with
messages on social media about like
people who are related to it so much
pursue that storyline and how that
specific storyline and inspired them to
come out and tell people you know and
how to like find a hero within
themselves you know to like seek the
help that they needed so it was good
yeah and also like you that your
character or you always stood the same
like you know your character very strong
like you could be like you could whole
[ __ ] down there like you could be lit up
like a cartel boss basically you know
cuz you know you're strong man you can
see in the show and you never got
pregnant I also like that part - well
actually I see I think that season four
I got pregnant yeah about that whole
thing of like making that decision for
yourself what's good even there that's
too strong decisions you know I can't
take care of this baby yeah well I got a
deal about how I gotta take care of
myself first not what a lot of people
whenever teenage brains do they never
think about the worth thinking about
it's always like instead of do we bash
you when I got my girlfriend praying in
high school
nobody said I'm we're gonna work this
through nobody ever say is this okay is
what's gonna happen you got somebody
pregnant you're 16 you're 17 okay so
what we're gonna do both of you guys no
no both family never get you're gonna go
okay we're gonna get through this Bobby
get our young we're gonna wash help you
guys with a baby love while you guys are
still in school you guys are gonna
graduate high school and you're gonna go
to college and we're gonna watch the
baby and that we're gonna help you out
this way now if I have to kind of help
in the beginning I would never have to
more my family it's gonna help me you
know where's the [ __ ] family when
somebody gets prayed about nobody
everybody hides but they don't thought
the same didn't want to talk to you
about protection you know the same
family never told me to pull out my
mother told me on my demo time that
color when you first put it in its gonna
feel so good not even I talked about the
burden is gonna be feel so good but you
got to pull out what we wonder the nice
when you were little and I kept telling
you to wait and wait you were getting
madder and madder
but if potagooos you run away with it
all at once that's all sexist
my mama just told me this you know baby
don't call me call us I felt like that
at 32 when I had myself I know oh my god
I was a grad school no no I was done I
was done with school she's crazy she's
crazy
I don't want to digress these lows hi
yeah he's a creator yeah and they
created it and worked with Planned
Parenthood and other social
organizations yeah like kind of make it
but see I respect that decision to get
an abortion because a lot of times
lately really since like Fast Times at
Ridgemont High
they don't do abortion stories where the
girl chooses that anymore not like it's
promoting it but it's not even showing
it as an option anymore or that somebody
some people do make that decision in
real life because in Fast Times at
Ridgemont High she gets an abortion that
same writer later on wrote singles she
gets in a car accident and the baby's
gone you know Matt you know conveniently
gone from the she had a miscarriage from
the car accident you know so she copped
out there but that does happen like she
had a one-night stand I got pregnant
from it she didn't have an abortion
she'd got an accident to an accident so
to do that choice it is hardcore now
yeah it's like we're getting more
conservative you know we don't show that
and the way Carlos roto is very
practical you know and they didn't make
a big deal about it was she just
basically said you know what I thought
about it and I'm I'm just I I just
dropped out of school you know and I'm
trying to get back and I just I have
this deal you know going on with the
lawyers and I'm young I don't have any
money I can barely afford a ticket to
you know go to the clinic like so
there's no way I can take care of a baby
and then her boyfriend was a drug dealer
too so it was like I keep there's no way
no one's gonna help me my mom's not
there no one my dad's not there
obviously so it was a very practical
decision for her she'd just like they
didn't make a big deal just you were
like the getaway driver right or the you
were driving or something from the
dealers right yeah in one of the seasons
okay that's right she was like doing
transportation she was doing runs with
that guy yeah yeah I was trying to
protect my boyfriend
a lot of women end up in prison
yeah exactly right new black yeah orange
is a new brown yeah how did you get that
wrong
you know I auditioned like everybody
else I everybody showed that addition
everybody got audition well some people
like Prince Royce you know some people
got that already had but popularity
there just kind of got offers but I
audition I I came out here like green I
was like hungry and I remember seeing
Blanca Valdez she was a casting director
I saw her at FedEx and I was printing
out some headshots and season one had
just happened and but I heard that they
were starting new storylines for for
East Lowe's high and I was like oh my
god I love that show I got to be on that
show it's like everything that I grew up
with and so I saw her and I was like I'm
just I'm just gonna go for it and I went
up to Blanc about this I was like hi
Blanca my name is Vanessa Vasquez I just
got to LA like about a year ago I'm
taking classes here and here's my
headshot resume like call me you know if
anything comes up and then we did a
couple panels afterwards you know she
said that that moment that I did that
she realized that I was gonna play
Camila she was like I just knew it like
I something like told me so I went in to
audition that must have been like
hundreds of girls that they auditioned
and it was like a three-month process
and I just kept going in and I'll say
they would tell me they're the first
time they're like okay do like this and
the second time I went in there like
okay not do it like that and then I
waited two more months and they call me
and did some chemistry reason like okay
now we want you to do it like this but
also with this and then also with that
and all that and I was like god damn I
was like all right so I just you know
you just got a go for it just give them
what they want and have no fear and so I
did and then a week later they call me
in there like you want to play Camila I
was like hell yeah and it was just like
the best call every you know man
those three months will kill me bro my
comedian fall out bro the suspense look
three months will kill me brother
oh man oh you drivel three month what
kind of job you had cuz I know like wait
that waiting and starving would have
killed me no you know actually that was
that was at the point where I had rose I
wasn't at Mel's anymore no I had just
finished two years being here and I and
honestly the hardest part about being
here is being here alone with no family
and especially I'm mexican-american I
grew up with a big family I was always
with my family like every weekend so
being alone that that feeling of
loneliness was killing me and so many
times I thought to myself like I'm just
gonna get in my car and I'm gonna pack
and I'm gonna go back to Texas because I
can't take it anymore I need to be with
my family and so then that audition
happened to had a callback and then I
was thinking I was in Texas and I was
really thinking like I'm just gonna stay
here I'm just not gonna go back like
like [ __ ] I gave it two years you know
and then but something kept telling me
like no wait hold on you know like go
back you know do you know just just wait
a little bit and then my manager at that
time had come and she's like gonna come
back they're doing auditions again they
want you to come back and although yeah
of course I'm gonna be right there you
know and then when I was in Texas I had
auditioned for they had called me to
audition for a film and I had booked
that film so that film actually brought
me back here and I shot it boom I was
called sins of a call girl and so I
really like this I was gonna play a
leaders my first film that I was gonna
play out here so that film brought me
back and while I was filming that the
first two weeks in January is when they
had called me to go back to do my
chemistry reads for East Louis and then
right after the film ended like that
last day I was on set they had called me
to tell me I was I had booked East LA hi
man you gotta be young to go through all
that though man you had 30 you know work
out were you auditioning relentlessly up
until that time when you're here for two
years no actually you know I wasn't
training I was training like it took me
a while to get like a real audition even
an agent it took me awhile that people
think like oh you know you're you're
cute you're pretty you know it's me no
problem but you got like I was competing
with people that had been in the
industry since they were little you know
so I knew I had a lot of cat
not to do I was like I don't have time
to play games I was in class like eight
hours a day for like a year and a half I
was trying to catch up with people who
had been like child actors you know I
had to really push myself so yeah I mean
it took me a while to get an agent even
my agent like I had to go be rich and
going about getting here like I only had
like 40 bucks in my account I did one of
those like you know it was workshop so
you could go meet the casting director
and the AJ and there was like 35 bucks
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
pay for it I'm gonna only live on five
bucks for the next two weeks if I have
to yeah and I went in did my audition
for them I did a comedic monologue and a
dramatic and I basically just laid it
down for her I was like look I'm working
my ass off I need a badass agent someone
who's gonna really help me and I have no
one to help me either you're gonna help
me or not if you want to call me later
and I walked out of the room and then
like four hours later they called me
they're like oh we want to rep you you
know it's like thank you finally you
know so yeah it's not you like you just
got a really push her stuff you believe
in something you work hard at it and
just beaching going home can go on about
it you got a scholarship I did I did
yeah I went in I had saved up some money
when I was in Texas I had done some
research I wanted to study at the best
acting school that a lot of my favorites
had studied and so I went over there and
then when I got there I ran out of money
like my first month I was like damn like
I'm not I mean I mean Texas you can live
off $6,000 for like at least six months
out here they were gone in like two
months and then I didn't know what to do
and so I saw that they had scholarships
and I just I was like I'm gonna try you
know what do I have to lose so I applied
I had done a lot of community work with
my theatre too and I think they really
like that
you know they really like that I was
using my my skills and talent for like
the better the community so they call me
and they're like yeah we're gonna give
you a scholarship you know whatever you
need to help you out here goes and so
like that was another miracle you know I
call my mom almost like oh my God thank
God you know like it was I just felt
like doors were opening for me you know
like they say that when you have a dream
the whole universe conspires to help you
achieve it and
like I just saw that as like a like my
little pathway part of my journey
yeah um you know right now I'm uh I
really look up to Eva Longoria Salma
Hayek America Ferrera like I love the
way that they've sort of taken into
their own hands that's entertainment
industry you know I'm becoming producers
so that's where I'm at right now and be
an actress slash producer and developing
my own content as well and so I I just I
look up to them a lot and I see like
damn they did it they paved the way I
feel like because they did it I can do
it too you know I just got to figure it
out like they did you know I never seen
brought a steam room
America Ferrera and Gina Rodriguez when
I think about I will America Ferrera all
the time on on superstore all the time
three episodes but still oh you top five
and you have a six when I leave and they
wanna see Gina orgy on TV I just heard a
no I did it Chicago was food you got
wine right here from East little higher
the new season sports he's watching that
show man oh the hoping it will bring me
in as a coach like you know you watch a
show you're rewriting oh yeah then
they're all right in there Felipe came
into the coach showed up with armpit
stains all the time
sweaty bag shorts and converse like
Jaime Escalante in there
but what about the switz I saw this
movie with Jack Black on Netflix it was
about part of my polish singers the king
he's a poker king bro but there's a
Ponzi scheme with all Polish people in
the area there's there's a steam with he
probably all these old people they're
gonna meet the Pope and he's right there
with what's-his-name rice worth it Jason
Schwartzman
he's also wet he's like we're doing
catch us they were a fighting meet the
Pope just for wearing a three-piece suit
sweat from the bottom and sweat in the
back just a walk through good luck good
luck because the Polka King yeah dude
looking for my Netflix movie coming out
next week so before these little high
you were not on any other show no I came
out here and that's funny because now
they stayed I've seen you once told
before you go hi Noah that my part no I
when I came out here you know a lot of
actors come out here because they got a
movie going on you know something that
brought him out here I didn't have
anything I just felt like everything
something in my gut was telling me she's
a call girl sense of conquer had me come
back know was before that like I am
people I just felt like it was time you
know I was like nothing I have nothing
else going for me and Houston it's time
to go
would you sure we should do that movie
bro which one's you because sins of the
guy who called the car girl sins of the
exterminator
[Laughter]
so with a fun working on the show
Kalitta like all those people now we had
a viene Harvey Weinstein no thankfully
any Harvey Weinstein OHS casting couch
Harvey wieners thank god man wouldn't
like hanging out with actors so no then
alley City College I want to stab all of
them bro all those thespians yeah
walking around like it's Fame I'm glad
bro that everybody's doing like in
acting class when I'm gonna Alec City
College it's nowhere around them I'm
still here you know what piss me off but
I think class at least Chloe bring it up
man I practiced a routine with these
three [ __ ] poured for a grade Ali
City College and I have fill it with me
I just marry your [ __ ] I will take my
son to school with me to call it what
I'm gonna miracle to junior college my
girl from that work and I was and I will
take him to school with me so that day
we're running late and my stupid ass
teach those [ __ ] went up there and
did the piece without me so I can oh
great yeah so yeah stay over here you
hear some screaming anything happening I
told him if anything happens went to the
office over there your grandma works
there Anna's mom your grandma works
there and I went over that to the guy
what you first of all man I have no tax
tax I have no way to talk to somebody
when I'm mad tact
no tact I have a publicist back there
feeding me lines I said listen you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
they started moon walking out of there
slowly how could you [ __ ] let them do
this [ __ ] without me in it man why you
knew I was in here
you should let someone else know why
they gotta go first you piece of [ __ ]
they never got quiet and then I just
walked away never seen enough we're
bonds and I ran
I'll tell my shopping he's gonna go geez
this is gonna go away I'm not gonna
forget you you [ __ ]
I'm never gonna [ __ ] forget you you
piece of [ __ ] I keep bumping into
another bonds you need to learn how to
teach talks about stories we just moved
to the class we don't want to know other
people that made it we know you didn't I
just because you know I'm a stand-up
comedian man we'll see that's the thing
when you go to acting class you have
something already that's your livelihood
you know you make a very good living so
you don't have to rely on that class as
much as these other people do it's a
side thing for you something you want to
go into but it's not the end of the
world if this class doesn't work out you
know and that's the attitude you go in
with dad's whatever the comedian listen
man I'm a stand-up comedian man my rows
are gonna come the way Kevin Hart's rows
come they're gonna be rich and for him
people right I walked in the least
funnier when I got there when I got
there I was like I thought they wouldn't
give me a smoke you know like America
Ferrera
the name tag man I'm too ugly for that e
I'm a warehouse guy all my life I was in
a warehouse there was a noise department
store to ugly your back in the house Oh
in the back of the house that would have
a like oh that would have been like a
seafood place I would have been a guy
putting the shrimp in the pudding guys
in the kitchen
yeah the cooks my first job was at
McDonald's and I like I really wanted to
work in the back like learn how to make
hamburgers and stuff I was all excited
like hey yeah I'm gonna make this she's
like no you're gonna go on the front
cuz you got a pretty smile got good
teeth we notice you don't have pimples
at the fryer over there
yeah I should bother that one that when
I would work with by size man you know
you know like you know what and he's
working too hard
I get lunchtime he still working when I
get the portable gonna be on the cover
you gotta be lazy like me I heard that
you were getting in the stand-up yeah I
should I just had my first stand-up show
last couple weeks ago I love it yeah
we're at flappers yeah it was fun you
know and it was kind of like what you
guys were talking about like you know
going into acting class but like to me I
was I always had stories like this what
they want to do you know and I respect
that you know but I was like I was
scared you know it was like oh man they
can have the good I have to go up and
like tell stories and make people laugh
that's hard like I respect you guys so
much and I always I just I'm so inspired
by the fact that you guys can go tell
jokes and inspire people at the same
time you know you just move the crowd so
every time I'm like I'm just like in
this other world when I watch you guys
so I just I wanted to try it out and I
was like let me just go see if I got
something I don't know so the first joke
my first joke was it about Oh was about
me growing up skinny and how like I said
whenever I was like skinny I the guys
they wouldn't talk to me because I had
no titties you know so I was like I
wanted to get some titties growing up
and I thought that I was gonna ever make
it out the hood I had to gave me some
titties
so I started chugging and sherée cans
and the guys really like like Vanessa
said you get anyway and I was like yeah
but when you're skinnier goes on the
wrong places and then come out to me and
be like yeah girl you look like a
two-pin of small little marble you
pregnant and I was like oh damn man and
so people actually got that I was like
ding but I went a lot better on flappers
I'm still learning Elsa learning in a
cleaner way you say that
I remember somebody told me if I cross
my arms mighty who get bigger but now
we're walking on like a worried woman
yeah no I was it we had I had a good
time people are X my jokes actually
landed at that time so it's how yeah man
have you get in the pickup line from
comedians yet hey we should hang out
hang out together right nobody want you
don't come you don't acting with tough
comedy comedy is different man right
here man we look like we look at unity
what we want you to make it stand-up
comedy is there what the only
congratulation when you bomb and then
they tell you they're good you know deep
down inside you did it that's when they
tell you they're good you're really
really funny
nobody's gonna welcome to you cuz you
don't need to there until you intimidate
them now there's no separate separating
now happen to me bro became a solo guy
and then and then your friends and then
your friends start asking funny are you
really funny I don't know how many
before me I only did it once
yeah but I've been doing a lot of open
mics for a while and I'm gonna keep
doing in too long conspire to get back
on doing it scary just look up open mic
and go to places right there were like
nobody goes only only one person or
better yet don't go alone cuz then it's
better to drive home alone and Digger
the body instead of keep you know we're
nowhere record yourself record yourself
yes I was doing that really help me out
to carry low book if you see something
stupid you write it down
like what would I write down the other
day I got no bug right here see Milo no
but yeah I'm working on them all working
on okay yeah right giggle radio just put
doing person nations give me something
hey hey you guys doing gentleman I saw
you I heard you doing chump earlier
oh yeah just keep doing what you do it
from your heart okay don't be a [ __ ] oh
it's like three steps removed from
Gandolfini it's good just saying you
could see how it could morph into a bird
dog you would a would crazy with the red
little drink before oh how you doing my
name is Nick Cage pleasure to meet you
oh yeah oh I'm sure he ended the night
there to like be under the piano oh my
god I used to go there man but nobody
knew me the air everybody spoke German
made you care for some time speaking
German all right bye
chief uh-huh yeah man it was only new me
every Monday night the big old bosom
ladies yeah that old or what the old
original ones still there long she's
been there since like no the other one
that kind of looks like an old dog the
old Bronwen the only to like a pug
calico house I think I know who she is
cos I will walk in there on Monday night
I only came in on Monday night and she
look at me go
Oh shoulder her life would drop like
with the people closer to ours now I
lose here closing for you know there and
the landlord's the setup there's a
daughter was there she acting like she
didn't know us no I would know they you
know your mom and dad went to Felipe oh
yeah I'm on a date right now
excuse me and then that other voice said
did you want a guy to bang my room I
used to live it now an Australian
comedian
you know man up on a place for 395 a
month where frog frog tongue man I still
live in the same street at immunity
better where he grew up and it was a
back house that had a tiny living room
or stand-up bathroom a toilet and a
window and a kitchen with a refrigerator
a little oven 395 but my wall was
connected to their house and their
daughter was 16 at the time but I she
might be 25 now but man I have to be
loud man and you hear the other time
excited be like and then when I fell off
the wagon it was like I got totally
drugged my first time drunk in like ten
years we were making loud noise when she
came knocking and we all hated would
knock and then we would knock and then
one more speaking of sour Dorian accent
which will reduce and/or share the kind
of beat that they look cool hanging out
a window a trailer tractor trailer like
little hillbilly
hanging on the window like fighter like
her phone was so big you could go flat
cut her toe my Thurmond feet I'm talking
about all mother mistakes he had long
toes hey the only thing I miss about
that place was the little dog fool max
my dog was so foolish over there self
barsky's right here what you got coming
up Magnus eyes a luxury stand-up career
no I just I just did an episode of the
brave and like I said I'm working on
developing my own TV show right now I'm
actually thankfully I'm working with
Lionsgate and it's about actually I
can't really say yet but as soon as
something comes up you know I gotta come
back
also bad if you ever ever ever wanna go
up again ever
okay well you go to a comedy show once a
month a nice audience and you could just
try it out on his show if you want like
a boy like performing and audiences
we're about to open Michaels Rodrigo
color brush we go and we have other
friends too Martin Rizzo Johnny and
those guys are really cool and you go
through their shows and then you just
pop in pop out in and out really good
writers they'll tackle you have jokes
what else oh your Twitter Instagram
everything by Nancy Duffy however it's
Vanessa Sita with - it our to an
analysis did um we would love to say
that we met that day but I think I saw
you that day
with one of the characters from East LA
I would you think all Awards yeah yeah
and I was there yeah Portuguese and I've
Cheech and Chong Cheech Maureen yeah the
only time theater a while back okay yeah
yeah I remember you were hanging out
with a Disney girl thing Disney girl
over the oil words I think we saw her
actually at the blood drive
NIC's Gonzalez oh yes the blood drive at
the Children's Hospital that's where we
saw her okay the guy with the socks
Gina there I was the last couple times
that they did it at the LA Times was the
first one yeah yeah it was a very first
one okay it was fine huh these are fun
huh it was fun you know uh was it was
Italy I'm not bad about I'm you know I
know bad about her she's like my skin
singer yeah the very first year I weigh
that was my first year in LA I was so
excited to get on the red carpet my
first red carpet I dressed all nice and
everything got a dress and then they
were clean I got there late I didn't
know there were certain time you had to
be there and then the UH one of the
photographer's stuck around he's like Oh
where'd he cleaned up you know all the
photographer's left but you know well
I'll take some pictures of the view I
was like oh he's so nice and this always
gonna walk around next to you no I just
I walk on the red carpet and there's no
photographer sir he's not even there and
I'm like looking around and it's I'm not
bad about it she just pulls up in this
limo and like this big old fur coat and
everyone was taking pictures of her and
I was like you know so was I grab my
phone I like if someone take a picture
of me and he comes back he's like oh my
bad I'm sorry
I'll take a picture of you so I never
that's like my first experience that
I'll never forget and I thought about I
took my take my shot came up attack hell
yeah so Vanessa
Vasquez Instagram and Twitter your
Twitter yeah everything's - eat avi yeah
- Sita vog going up bedewing spots
during the week and what else that's it
this Friday worth the spotlight 29 Larry
bubbles brown with real Torres myself it
is sold out
next we were yet in Tucson Sahuarita
desert diamond sold out you better hurry
nice and this Friday actually if you're
listening to this right now you better
get up
and get in your car and make it to the
minute hasta on First Street but we're
gonna be studying tickets cash money
we're gonna get tickets that yes the
minute us and Boyle Heights we're gonna
be giving out chilaquiles yeah there's
some chilaquiles vegan vegan vegan pan
dulce that's made my role from says I'm
gonna be mad I don't know how he's
making it I doubt he's using el pato
sauce this is I know it's your preferred
way but I yeah are you vegan yeah he's
making vegan pan dulce and we're making
I think he's making enough for 200
people so it should be good and then
coffee free coffee for about 200 people
I think was so full shut up to
SuperSonics publicist policies right
SuperSonics media SuperSonics media
that's the Pope your publicist yeah mine
too man let me call me too much though
[Laughter]
question perfect I never had publicity
but I don't know man I'm old-school bro
just tell me where to go what is it that
he's almost like you're a little bit
more with it than Joey Diaz you're more
I know that they were they help Gabriel
it says I would like really that guy
hates press he hates it you I remember
one time he saw Chris Rock say the
reason I want to be famous because I
don't wanna do press in the morning but
then I thought about it no man you can
never avoid that movie coming out you're
gonna do prayers from [ __ ] 5:00 in
the morning to attends then you're gonna
get there from 10 or 12 you're gonna get
the middle of America and then you're
gonna go back and do West Coast so
you're gonna do eight hours of press for
a week am i lyin
you did a ton of press for like four
weeks before your special came out and
it's clear yeah I had to practice too
and I had to like figure out how to say
certain words like okay
I'd be like I love is passing was fool
don't forget people East lows high and
coach oh Vanessa baskets you heard her
on the western food podcast and you tell
them I'm a big fan of your new comedy
[Applause]